you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at another game between alpha zero
and stock fish in this game alpha zero
is playing as black II for e5 game Ray
Lopez Berlin defense and d3 Bishop c5
minor piece and balance is now present
castles Knight d7 so where six moves in
of the ten games that have been released
to the public two of them alpha zero
played as black and in both of those
games we have this same exact position
so when stockfish plays the role of has
apparently alpha zero is a fan of the
berlin defense what does this mean well
maybe it'll have some influence on the
top players of the world Mike the Berlin
defense become more popular I guess
we'll have to wait on that now in the
other game between these two stockfish
continued with a central expansion in
this one it's Knight B to d2
castles Queenie one f6 and Knight c4 so
from e1 a couple ideas behind this move
for one f4 is desirable so the Queen may
later look to come out towards the Kings
side and another from e1 she is
facilitating some Queen side expansion
so anticipating this punch against the
bishop we have rook f7 this idea to
vacate f8 is common both the knight or
the bishop can make use of that square
but to play the rook to f7 instead of EA
twitch I feel is more natural you know
it definitely caught my attention so I
just want to share a thought or two with
these two posts for one maybe with the
rook on f7 the Queen wants to at some
stage come to EA and do similar like the
White Queen and another if at some stage
the D file becomes relevant alright
there's some target for black to attack
now the rooks can form a battery in just
two moves again just some rough thoughts
but whenever I see some kind of you know
something that strikes me is a little
bit off I question things these are this
is what I do
continuing
a four
Bishop f/8 white is getting off of this
diagonal wants to play out four so the
king in the corner is much more secure
well if you're going to play out 495 a
596 and you know it might even be one
other detail behind rook f7 and I know
this one's going to be really far out
there but I'm gonna say it anyhow maybe
is to bait stock fish into the following
sacrifice Knight takes e5 follows pawn
takes knight Knight takes pawn and the
rook is hit he won't be hit if he was on
EA again I don't know these things for
certain I'm just throwing them out there
make what you want of them is this a
justified sacrifice let's see what
follows black white just sacrificed a
night and got two pawns for it
rook f6 follows Knight g4
rook F 795 does this look familiar we've
been here before how many times is this
going to repeat
if the rook goes to f6 basically were
headed for a threefold repetition draw
says no play ball this is a very awkward
post for the rook for sure interfering
with the bishop in the Queen
a little uncoordinated but the game
continues black wants more a six follows
I already pointed out white gave up a
knight got two pawns but is also now
getting a little bit more as well what
is this well the black Queen side
structure is going to be very weakened
with a six
this is putting a dent in blacks queen
side without the b-pawn around the sea
pawns the apon become very weak you
can't take him because of Knight takes
c6 with the fork
see five is played
f-for Queen e8 okay so now black is
prepared to not take the pawn here but
rather maintain a or acquire let's say a
very strong Queen side structure with b6
now that c6 is defended so that's why at
this point we have a takes B bishop
takes and many weaknesses on the Queen
side now black is not too well
coordinated here
continuing queen a5 white has some very
active pieces the bishop in the king
rook are not really contributing just
yet but definitely the major pieces on
the a file and the knight that is in
blacks house Knight d4
that's defended with the Queen
Queen takes pawn move there's this
tactical shot of rook takes Knight Queen
takes Knight rook c5 the black pieces
make use of the c5 square with this
variation black is giving up upon but
again has c5 for the rook maybe even the
bishop in some cases Queen c3 in the
game
rookie six Bishop e3 rook b6 so this for
the moment is tying down the Queen to
the defense of the pawn Knight c5 rip B
4 B 3
a five so this was another moment in the
game I thought a five what is that about
white is giving up upon with this move
where is the compensation so in order to
see that's this compensation you have to
question a couple things one what pieces
get exchanged after this chop-chop
what just happened with that sequence
well this is a very active rook in this
guy here black stroke is passive
there's some compensation active rook
exchange for a passive rook
Bishop takes Knight
Knight c4 and rook da follows so this
backwards move is actually developing
milf the rook wants to be here there's
no action in the senate's it's not like
it's it's a knight on d4 much different
the rook doesn't function well in d4 and
Knight would the rook wants to be on a a
continuing both sides produce a flight
square now g3 and now h6 so these are
the two flight squares this definitely
caught my attention stock fishes choice
to play g3 here more common I thought it
would be to play h3 have the h2 squares
a pocket it's much more secure against a
major piece getting to the second rank
what's a difference with g3 well yes the
King is more vulnerable to major piece
pressure on the second-ranked but at the
same time at least f4 is secure okay
the rook doesn't want to stay here
babysitting the pawn forever he wants to
be able to go over to the a file the
open file that's a difference between
these two moves h3 and g3 you can be
sure if f4 wasn't defended by the rook
you know if h3 was in likes going to put
pressure on this sensitive point one way
or the other
so after h6 we have queen a5 she doesn't
have to watch over that c2 point anymore
Bishop took out that night so the Queen
is now very active hitting both Bishop
and pawn bishop c8 these guys are now
very well organized the bishops are back
home
and nice harmony black gives up upon
with this last move the materials
restored white has three pawns and black
has the bishop black has the bishop pair
and they're going to cause the White
King a serious problem this is one of
the benefits with having the bishop pair
where is there a safe color for the
enemy King to now go to the bishops are
always able to question the king's post
go to a light square we got the light
square bishop around dark square dark
square bishop so where is the safe home
bishop h3 follows the rook is hit
the g2 square the flight square is now
taken away from the king and the rook
would really like to go to the open file
but he can't do that is to make a very
passive move rook g1 is played
if the hrickos to the open file the
Queen now sneaks into f3 or even E - so
what does rookie one do how's that a
defense of this move
well if Queen h5 there's this g4 advance
interfering with the Queen getting to f3
and keep in mind if the Queen plays to
h5 here this rook is vulnerable so first
we have rook at d7 so changing of the
guard the bishop now has this
responsibility so the Queen is now free
to do some other things queen h5 is now
the threat
Queeny five
welcoming a queen exchange and
preventing queen h5 so the Queen's are
now gone the rook definitely gets over
to the open file
where does he really want to be a to to
exert pressure on the weakest pawn in
White's camp c2 Knight c4 follows this
is move 35 and one that I stared at for
quite some time
what you're seeing on screen right now
is that the recommendation by stockfish
aid is rook to c1 and as soon as the
move Knight c4 is played you see a big
shift with the evaluation it was equal
ish I'm just gonna go back it's equal
ish with rook to c1 but after Knight c4
is played there's a big you know a big
difference with those two moves so I let
it sit and think for a little bit you
know once I got to about depth 36 37
area those these two moves here Knight
c4 and rook c1 were much closer and
evaluation and in both cases it was
about a minus 0.7 right around that area
so why is Knight c4 plate is the big
question in order to understand this
let's see what would happen if c1 is
played the top move
dock fish thinks is g5 at depth 28 29
right now 30 but instead of g5 there's
something even better that black can do
and that would be the move see for a
pawn sacrifice in order to do what
cause the white King a giant headache
Bishop c5 would follow how is the King
getting out
killer bishops if white tries to negate
the bishop no the Bishop slips into f2
and soon you're also gonna have the rook
slipping in to the second rank
how would white defend this I want to
play it out just a few more moves to
show the type of bind black and place
white in and eventually this Bishop can
dislodge the night with this little
maneuver these puns are guarding a lot
are controlling a lot of ground but it
doesn't this whole side of the board
let's say these five ranks who cares
about these five ranks this right here
is where the action is and this is where
black has all the pieces and the King is
stuck in the corner talk about
completely defensive pieces on the white
end
short story night c4 prevents black from
vacating the c5 square to the bishop
continuing g5 rook c1
white wants to get the King playing very
soon so the rook goes here anticipating
some rook a to move Bishop g7
the bishop wants to get to d4 white says
no
rook a8 this was instructive I think
many would just jump right into a - but
from a a the rook is super flexible from
a eight this stops the idea of the king
trying to get active with King g1 King F
- if king g1 in this position black
could capture and then put pressure here
and there's no defense to that threat
so what's tried is Knight f3 this should
be - bishop c3 Knight g1
trying to dislodge this pesky bishop
capturing once allows the rook to attack
the knight and if then the knight goes
back here there's going to be an issue
let's just play this one variation out
rook f8 Knight g1 can be met with Bishop
to f1 and then rip to f2 the black
pieces are invading
in the game it's night g1 Bishop d7 92
Bishop d2 rook d1 Bishop e3 he's secure
for at least a move now he has hit a
couple times back to back there
both Knight and rook you secure here no
way to get out him directly now King g2
now the LightSquared Bishop comes right
back in look at how well coordinated
they are taking away multiple squares
from the king the knight and the rook
the Knights in a pin rook e1 and Bishop
to d2 rook F 1 is the move played in the
game playing here there would be a cool
tactic rook to d1 can you spot the
tactic if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video what move would black play in
this position okay the winning shot
would be to simply capture on f4 and if
takes Bishop f3 with the nice fork and
then soon black is going to be promoting
so in the game it's rook f1 rook a to h3
Bishop takes Knight and black is going
to lose that piece back but at least
gets upon
material is still balanced but these two
guys here restrict these four pawns and
then some
so this Bishop helps out controlling
these four pawns and also plays a role
on the King side as well has some
influence on these squares so rook f2
King g7 g4 in a bishop to d4 so the rook
has two tasks or is trying to perform
these two tasks one stop the King from
approaching the center in to defend the
pawn bishop d4 says choose one so the
rook defends the pond
6 + e 5 this is basically the last point
in the game to touch on e5 is giving
away a pond to try and activate the king
but I can just pick up the pond and
question the Kings position even if he
gets here he can be boxed out by the
king so playing out a few more moves the
rook has ideas of maybe coordinating on
the g3 square so Bishop f4 c3 is only
creating more targets for the black rook
again there's this idea of rook to e3
and getting into g3 so this is these
pawns are now just gonna drop one by one
with this last move now all three are
target's white was already struggling to
defend the one base point so there's no
defense when there's now three different
targets 14 black so these pawns simply
fall one by one from here and not too
long off from this stage we're going to
have team white throw in the towel after
move 67 Bishop to d6 stockfish resigns
now if it did continue this is one of
the many ways it could have finished up
the pawns getting all captured and this
guy here on the G file continuing to
push and straight to a pretty cool mate
with Bishop to e3
so one more to add with this game stop
fish your next sacrifice in exchange for
my two pawns was not completely
justified
moreover the synergy of my bishop pair
demonstrated that King could not obtain
a safe haven if your knight sacrifice
was played to ultimately secure a draw
by threefold repetition well the great
McHale talk could not approve of such
tall said quote to play for a drop at
any rate with white is to some degree a
crime against chess end quote
you